So let's see if we can compare the flash
disk and the combination of the two.
Let's say that we have a user who
will play a game for two hours, and
the game issues reads to 2 GB of data
and writes to another 10 MB of data.
And then after these two hours the user
switches to watching a movie for
two hours where throughout this two
hours we will read 1 GB sequentially.
And then the user does
this three more times.
If we have a disk that can read 100
MBs a second, if we read sequentially,
and read or write 1 MB per second,
if we do it randomly, and
if we have flash that can access
1GB per second either way.
What is the total access time for
all the data here, if we use disk?
What is the total access time with
the disk in this whole, 4 times 4 hours?
What is the total access
time if we use pure flash?
And what is the total access
time if we have a disk and
a 4 GB flash cache that
is initially empty?